i am a child labor survivor and forced
marriage survivor
my name is nasrin say i come from
very rural village on the border of
india nepal
most of the people are undocumented
which means like the people who born
there or died there there's no
birth certificate so because of that
i also don't know how old i am i can
guess
25 26 27 years old my village was
completely
male dominated society and i
saw my aunt being murdered for speaking
up
for herself and i witnessed my 12 year
old sister being
forced into marriage and my mom she said
that
this is what happened to me this is what
is happening to your sister
and someday it will happen to you i
chose to
run away the village because i did not
want
wanted
to be forced into marriage one of my
cousin who was working in the sweatshops
he took me from the village
to kathmandu when i was around nine or
ten year old when i came to the short
show for the first time they teach me
how to
do the stitch just straight and then i
was keep practice practice i would do
the blooming and i would wash the dishes
or collecting the water but
mostly in the machine and my machine was
like higher than me
so we had to put other stack of clothes
so i couldn't fit
the machine it took me almost two months
to look out of the window because i was
so scared
i come from like such a such a small
village and then all of the sudden i'm
in the big city
it gave me a shock in the sweatshop six
of us
four of them were adult lived worked
slept
in ten by ten room without bed or
bathroom
or having access to even clean drinking
water we were paired
less than two dollars and forced to work
almost 12 to 15 hours a day
we had piles of orders like 500 pieces
600 pieces and we needed to finish that
on time and if we did not finish we will
not get paid at all
so for that reason we had to wake up
sometime
4 am 5 am and work all the way to
midnight and still the pile of clothes
will be not finished we didn't had any
day off like seven days work work like
one order will come and the second
order is coming back again it was like
cycle
sometimes we also would die my hand
would stay black
almost for a week and then i would put
kerosene in my hand and try to take off
that color and then the kerosene
is like a smell when i would eat food
the rice and lentils were like
very low nutrition food they give and my
food
all of the dust of the clothes like the
little fibers will go into
the food and often i would pick up like
that long threads from my food
so much chemicals are dyed in those
clothes and then eventually it gets
discarded into the rivers
and end up in the oceans also it harms
the earth too fashion is one of the
most floating industry in the world i
was not completing the whole piece i was
doing just one part
and label or tagging was happening
somewhere else the designs were same and
same like fast fashion
thousands of pieces being repeated on
and on our part was to just
stitch my little fingers they were like
fast as machine because
i knew that in order to get a little bit
of rest
i need to be fast and that is when i
felt like i was not a human
i felt like a machine and i just
hated those clothes they were woven with
the energy of my suffering
many many times when i was in the
sweatshop i would collapse onto the
large bundle of clothes that i was
making like i didn't even had a bed
and i would just daydream like where
these clothes are going to who's going
to wear them
i started to talk to the shirt or the
clothes that i was making and
talking to the shirt and saying whoever
will wear these clothes i hope they can
feel me
i hope they can feel my blood i hope
they can see my tears
because as a young child i just wanted
to go
to sleep and it was not possible
and i tell people that
like whoever is wearing those clothes
and some people are wearing those
clothes right now
and they don't know if you don't know
where your clothes are where your things
comes from
you might be consuming suffering i want
people to know
where your things come from so you don't
have to consume suffering
after working two years in the sweatshop
it got shut down
the agent ran away with two months of
our salaries and rest of the other
people who were working with me they
went to find
work in another sweatshop and i became
in the daytime
street kid and the sweatshop room in the
nighttime that was the place that i
would come and sleep and that
is when i met complete stranger he was a
monk
and he was living in nepal and this man
became like my mentor and he started to
give me
education how to read and write and with
that
i was able to seize my destiny the
switch-up room
that space that is where my teacher
would come
for like one or two hours and teach me
and at the same time the machine that
was left over i started to use this
machine and whatever the skills that i
have learned in the sweatshop
i started to make bags and purses and
instead of like selling to the agent
this time i was selling to the store and
that brought
little bit more income to my life and
then
also gave me a dream that i can educate
more women's and girls who are just like
me who are working for this whatsapp
were abandoned and disadvantaged by the
societies
so i started to bring slowly these women
and girls into that place
and i took a loan and then with that
loan i brought like one machine to
machine
and then we were like six women we
started
local women's handicraft shop and that
became the way to
express our activism and what ethical
fashion looks like
that became like a hub and all these
people from all around the world started
to come and our story
got published in 2012 in forbes magazine
and we didn't even know what forbes
magazine is
because when you are focused in your
mission
magic works you know and the people that
you need it comes to the life in 2013
we built our women's empowerment center
so far we have trained over hundreds of
women
and we are making sure everybody is
being paid living wage
the working conditions are good there's
clean water
we have organic gardens and that center
is becoming a place for rest of the
other society as an example
this is how the work space should be
look like back in nepal
even i am published in forbes and i'm
running these businesses
my society in 2012 they tried to force
me into marriage with a man i never met
or talked once but with the help of
my friends and families and my teacher
back then
i was able to survive that and i was
able to escape
that to the women the girls who are
listening and who are
feeling they're not enough they can't
make that change
i want them to just take one step my
first one
step was just to leave that village and
be in the street and when i was in the
street then i was in the bus and then i
had to climb through
all this mountain to come all the way
here
and it just that little step that brings
you
to who you are and why you are here
in 2015 when i came to america and i
walked to these major stores
that is when i realized like oh my god
people are buying without knowing what
happens the other side
right now america is consuming 40
percent more
than they used to consume 20 years ago
america imports 3.1 trillion dollars of
goods and services from all over the
world and that contains slavery
our phone the computer the clothes at
what cost
it is producing first of all i would say
to these companies that
stop importing human slavery it's like a
chain
so on the certain chain some people
knows but they keep the information
hidden
most of these unregulated manufacturers
use
all these undocumented individuals who
work from like secret and illegal
sweatshop
that are hidden in these all unmarked
buildings
throughout inner cities and slums and
villages
because the companies are not mapping
their supply chain
that is where the disconnection is
because ceos
are most focused on quantities and fast
that's it not necessarily the quality
also because that is why the shirt that
you will buy in the fast fashion you
wear for like
few months and then it falls apart and
rest of the
human part and nature part climate part
it's just not even in our awareness
you can make a difference the world is
really
counting on you and as long as you step
into that power
there will be change and a fast fashion
is destroying and taking over the
humanity
you are the catalyst for that change
alone
i can do something but together we can
do massive things
you